we begin this night with a fox news
alert day eight of the kyle rittenhouse
trial is now officially in the books now
only closing arguments remain and then
the jury they will begin deliberation of
course the entire case could still be
thrown out the prosecutors have been
credibly accused of misconduct and their
case is extremely weak wendy rittenhouse
kyle's mother will join us for an
exclusive interview tonight and greg
jarrett and professor alan dershowitz
they'll be here with the latest legal
analysis now tonight many are
questioning why this case ever made it
into a courtroom at all
was there over charging involved and of
course the contemptible behavior of the
prosecution we have compelling video
evidence showing kyle rittenhouse being
threatened being chased violently
assaulted by an angry mob look at your
screen one man trying to right there
stomp on his face and stomp his face
into the pavement another attempted to
grab his firearm while yet another man
you can see it right there on your
screen
literally pointed a loaded handgun at
rittenhouse's face according to
eyewitness accounts and video evidence
all three individuals who were shot were
attempting to cause great bodily harm
potentially death to then 17-year-old
kyle rittenhouse before he discharged
his legal weapon which according to
wisconsin state law would make this a
clear case of self-defense whereby an
individual may use force if he or she
quote reasonably believes that such
force is necessary to prevent imminent
death or great bodily harm to himself or
herself now the prosecution is obviously
desperate yesterday prosecutors were
reprimanded over and over again by the
presiding judge for impugning
rittenhouse's right to remain silent
some accuse them of intentionally
causing a mistrial or trying to in order
to get a clean slate and begin a new
trial because it's going so badly today
the judge continued to admonish
prosecutors for their unethical behavior
yet again take a look
does real america's voice have any sort
of
um
political
uh bias or agenda or anything like that
and what is the relevance it goes to the
bias of the witness your honor
uh the
bias in what respect i assume that
people
we uh as i come at the beginning this is
not a political trial
that's an attorney that you uh have out
of madison no objectives at all what's
the relevance of this well your honor
we've had a lot of questions about other
people relevance of this
i would like to know why he felt the
need to retain an attorney to provide
video in this case i think it goes to
bias i think it goes to credibility
it's been asking other witnesses
retain an attorney that's how desperate
they are a guy that was literally a
witness that swore to tell the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth so
help me god now clearly this case is not
going well for the prosecution now
reports that kenosha and perhaps even
other cities are bracing for sadly
another round of violent riots well
maybe liz cheney and madam kinziger and
the democrats maybe they should form a
committee they should look into the what
about 534 riots from the summer of 2020
you know the riots that killed dozens of
people injured thousands of police
officers they were pelted with bricks
and rocks and bottles and molotov
cocktails and worse and also resulted in
billions of dollars in stolen businesses
other businesses burned to the ground
people like kamala harris your vice
president out there promoting bail funds
january 6 we said it on day one was
wrong it can't happen in this country
people that break the law need to be
held accountable or what about the
people that were involved in the riots
in 2020 by the way liz cheney where's
that committee where's your discussion
about the constitution on that issue do
you believe in equal justice and
application of our laws if you do it's
time for you to speak up now the media
mob by the way and top democrats they
all told their mindless followers from
the get-go in this case that kyle
rittenhouse was guilty as always they do
what they always do they rush to
judgment they ignore due process the
presumption of innocence and of course
they they create an atmosphere where
people expect a certain outcome that
often doesn't happen because their
information is wrong faulty and
political for example on the campaign
trail without any evidence whatsoever
joe biden accused kyle rittenhouse of
being a white supremacist now
congresswoman presley also accused him
quote of white supremacy house
democratic leader hakeem jeffries who
frequently speaks out against mass
incarceration he tweeted this week lock
up kyle rittenhouse and throw away the
key and meanwhile even basketball star
lebron james posted a video of kyle
rittenhouse emotional crying yesterday
in court tweeting quote laughing face
emojis with the caption quote what tears
i didn't see one man knock it off that
boy ate some lemon heads before walking
into court really lebron one fake news
cnn hack accusing rittenhouse of fake
crying or crocodile tears and not to be
outdone msdnc referring to the trial as
white privilege on steroids you can't
make this up take a look
when written health got emotional it may
have come across the jury as a genuine
expression of remorse or on the other
hand
maybe it was crocodile tears designed to
elicit sympathy this is white privilege
on steroids
ridden house testified that after he
shot
all of these people
he approached the cops and told them
that he'd been involved in a shooting
and the officers told him
be careful so that you don't get pepper
sprayed and go home
it's impossible to imagine that
happening to a black or brown person
white privilege on steroids crocodile
tears lock them up throw away the key
what happened to due process presumption
of innocence innocence until being
proven guilty look at this actual quote
from nbc news if convicted he'll become
a right-wing martyr if he's freed it's a
message to others like him that prison
won't be in their future even worse in a
now deleted tweet cbs news that they
basically claimed rittenhouse murdered
two men uh that has yet to be determined
that will be up to the jury and most
likely unless of course this case gets
thrown out with prejudice now these
outlets these celebrities these
democrats they do this time and time
again they should all be ashamed of
themselves they're vilifying an 18 year
old man declaring he's guilty because of
what because of their partisan political
beliefs have any of them ever bothered
to watch the tape have they bothered to
look at any of the evidence in this case
did they not see the star prosecution
witness admit that he pointed a loaded
gun at kyle rittenhouse before kyle shot
him on this program we make it a policy
we never rush to judgment we believe in
due process we believe in the
presumption of innocence doesn't matter
if you're a liberal conservative
democrat or republican we believe in the
rule of law and our constitution and
this is important we look at the
evidence we make phone calls we research
we do investigative reporting we follow
the truth wherever it is that's why when
you look at the track record of this
program in particular i was right about
richard jewell uh that's why we were
right on the duke lacrosse case that's
why we were right on the uva case that's
right why we were right about ferguson
missouri and cambridge and baltimore and
and so many other cases we actually took
the time like in the duke
lacrosse case i met with the families in
ferguson i actually talked to
my sources on the ground that told me
very early on there were eyewitnesses
many of them that corroborate the story
of officer darren wilson anyone in the
media care to do that any of these
democrats hollywood stars do they ever
make phone calls i doubt it democrats
media mob hollywood their own political
beliefs and feelings are much more
important than what would represent
journalism truth and justice for them
the narrative the politics seems to be
the only thing that matters it's
short-sighted it is dishonest frankly
it's immoral no matter what happens with
this case i cannot give you the outcome
at this hour kyle rittenhouse and his
family they deserve better than that
from these people with high profiles
they're also creating an atmosphere
where people expect a result that
probably if i had to bet in all
likelihood won't be coming